hey we found Habib we finally found him
he's right here as I hit that how are
you and should be for everyone Habib
number-one important most important
cross these days connect will again
recognize always have to pray you always
need to stay humble in space you know
the media is feeding the garbage to
these people welcome to the D show thank
you
in Florida where are we going now
brother I go to American Top Team check
it out the brothers a little wee all
right let's so you guys read this we'll
check it out American Top Team here in
Florida so a leak aitikaf if you guys in
watch the program we did before he
actually he gave up doing the
professional fighting for his Dean
that's something amazing about the
brother Tom did not there's our friend
member we had him on the show Hector
Lombard Hector where you been brother we
got to see you again
you let you left your belt here Hector
found more of our brothers here you
doing brother what's your name awliyas
help my brother from where you
understand hey we found a beep we
finally found them he's right here is
ahead is that happy I think we found her
beep okay look look look look take a
look good we found her beep listen
brother you cannot run it you still then
send me location to be I'm over here
looking for you and we're gonna find you
in sha allah the best that you come
okay let's make it happen don't avoid
your brother lately
nice I heard you guys yes like I'm Alex
well one of your students are you doing
say hello to the world are you doing the
world beautiful world how are you
we're boxing here hey listen brother I'm
here but I don't see him man we buy last
time I came looking for you Habib I
can't find it where's Habib nah can't I
don't see he didn't send me though the
location so I got to go looking for him
but he's not here where is it
we need location brother huh so we need
his location to find hevene location
Dagestan mahadji Allah so I'm here I
don't I didn't find you hubby please
don't make me go to the next one okay
send me the location let's do this under
Dean Shaw
all right so for it for you because
Dagestan has been on the map most of the
fighters know about it now so give us a
breakdown so you got you got Dagestan
and then what are the other places now
there so the whole area called hoax
Moulton caucus mountains yeah this is
over there is a Ossetia Dagestan
Chechnya Ingushetia kabardino-balkaria
karachay-cherkessia Abkhazia a lot of
little little little ones and the big
ones everybody probably know a little
bit away but Georgian Armenia and
Azerbaijan
so all this areas called smaller there's
a north and the south
[Music]
how you doing coach hey we're good well
I'm illegal lake wa salam welcome to the
d show yes
peace be with you yeah yeah yes more
some other fighters here are you doing
afraid I do me are you doing sailor nice
to meet yo these shorties yeah yeah yeah
I do everybody good you made an
interesting point I mean just by
changing people's perception of Muslims
because as ignorant as it sounds it is
something that's common people think of
Muslims are terrorists that people start
to hate Muslims but just you know the
people you've met you know over the
years many of the professional fighters
now they have a different outlook
because they actually got to meet
Muslims they don't know most of us as
their neighbors you know people around
recognize we're Muslims this was a story
I tell the brother he was a Marine
soldier he's one of the coaches over
here and something happened somewhere
and he say man I hate Muslims and then
he tell to the guy who's actually say
the Shahada today he say no no no I take
my words back because of brothers like
Ali and the guys other because we around
us people you know they see us they
understand this now when we teach this
not what we preach alam is a different
agent is not you know the media is
fitting the garbage to these people and
all the people who don't know of course
they're gonna believe because the guy
come in a suit telling you and you think
everything in the news come out is true
for all news as a liar so don't believe
the height connect with the muslim
continue to watch the deen show even
though the brothers are fighting we're
not talking about that but they still
they still make their salat they still
are connected to their dean correct
towards all of the brothers great long
time doesn't matter where they're they
stopped on the street they go to pray on
the street all of them is fasting all of
them is follow the deal you know they
follow the pillars of islam and a man
all the muslims they were all sinners
that's deep mad because there's too many
people they abandoned they've abandoned
the salaat the basic pillar of Islam but
look at this this is a this is nothing
you know okay you might not agree that
they give them exchange of fighting but
they still hold it on and she'll go back
off from this to it they're still
holding on to their Dean in the crowd to
be a movement they not you know scared
to go and pray right up on to the cops
over here they don't care we have a
bunch of cups
CIA guys will change with us at the gym
they're praying follow us and actually
this kind of sound our to because when
people see us they kind of respect it
and they're all there's very nice how
you worship and how you frustrate you
know in greeting to the God right in
front of everybody without shame it's
kind of some sort of the Dawa to for the
people and this is guy this is so
important nowadays we follow the growing
Islamophobia that you're
unapologetically Muslim and Muslim is
simply one who submitted their will to
the crater trying to be the best human
being that you can be go out tomorrow
Jake welcome to the D show thank you you
know people who lack motivation you have
70% of people overweight overweight
sitting on the couch getting fat yeah
what advice do you have for people to be
get out there to take care of their body
and their health man stay positive you
know stick to the positive things you
know you have to always there's always a
negative side and a positive side you
don't want the negative side so stick we
stick it with the positive side and
believe that everything is possible when
you do that things happen beautiful
thank you it was beautiful to see
the brothers who are professional
athlete when it's time to make some that
but the brothers didn't go ahead and put
training ahead of their salaam so they
stopped it's a good time out I'm gonna
make the prayer this is so important
does that connection your lifeline to
your Creator and thank your creator for
the blessing that he's given us and it's
so beautiful to see Ali pay the call all
the brothers here that I've met the
brother looked like Kobe all these
brothers taking a time out to go ahead
and think they're great at the created
the heavens and earth in Arabic Allah I
leave in the st. Peter Wong Russia so
he's also in the UFC
hey Sultan I think we found her be
finally for the D shows this Habib years
is that the beasts stay here like it's
time that you snuggle okay Abbey fan
but he looked like a beer ah yes we'll
say you know you have to have awareness
you have to know when it's time to
change your life you have to know when
it's time to increase your performance
as far as physical fitness we need to
get out need to workout you need to make
sure that you're eating healthy eating
vegetables drinking a lot of water and
making sure that you're cutting out all
the processed foods and all the fast
foods those are those are the things
that are actually killing us you know so
understanding that and getting more
educated in an overall health and
fitness it's going to be a key factor
when you're talking about increasing
your longevity in life I like what he
said you hear that because we've been
talking about that avoid fake food eat
real food and that's what's killing the
people to fake food are true true very
very I'll let you get back to to the to
the class takes a lot guys because I
often say venison people don't think
like you weren't you and be able to
throw a jab to a hug you and being able
to walk into that cage or do any of
these things without the blessings that
because many people don't stop after the
quiet and they'll think this coach and
that Coach and of course you know you
think the people right but many people
forget to thank their creator for year
for everything we have actually we have
this arms and legs and eyes and air we
breathe being an earth through walking
is a lot everything is closed upon allah
tala and this what we have to do is
every day of our life we have to be
grateful for him because he's the one we
all need to know for you and should be
for everyone Habib number one important
most important for us these days connect
will again recognize always have to pray
you always need to stay humble
stay calm and cool my brother javi Alex
Alex how are you so time to learn
you brought your belt with you I was
like now being a champion wear the belt
come back a lot of tensions a lot of
money like crazy smell stuff my local
cleanest and most important thing for
you this was fun nice having and we're
looking forward to having you on the
real show the Dean show what do you say
brother let's do it
send me the locations just send me
location thank you so much guys you send
him a message we looking for him to send
location so we could get him with a good
show
James cannot agree with you Susan few
careers so we gotta get him soon to come
when he's back to Chicago on the D show
you let him know okay Bobby we looking
for you alrighty I'm done the projected
image it doesn't prohibit like if you're
training kickboxing or if you're
training jiu-jitsu a wrestling you know
that's fine there's no common with that
but now obviously we don't want to
forget the Hadees of problem hamsa days
Saddam before beat us to punch each
other in the face and you know but train
for yourself is you know to be an
athlete to just you know put defend
yourself and your family is a good thing
you do you have to be this have Hadees
read about Allah loves the most
we all have to be in a good shape too
because if we're gonna look backwards at
the Sahaba so tell me there was a lawyer
there was a once there was athlete right
there was a warrior and we just have to
be strong as a Dean I don't say you
don't have to study of course you have
to study but push with that you have to
work it out because me I have a law
degree
I'm a lawyer so you don't always have a
degree and we are also fashion outlets -
so we just showed him a reaction that's
right we said we're gonna be not leaving
them alone until we find them right yeah
how's that huh not gonna leave you alone
you don't come and go give him the
interview the main the main thing that
you know is very interesting especially
for the youth now like some beautiful
things that Habib said one stay
connected to God to keep it humble
breathe what was the other one
so you tell me and stay connected to
Salah to prayer
we're gonna do right now we're gonna
play mothers we're gonna mix a lot we'll
be back